foreign
Sacramento hi Jason welcome to the
Ramsey Show
good afternoon Jaden Dave so my
financial plan has 80d I I I'm kind of
all over the place with my baby steps
why
um well I've been listening to you guys
for a number of years I follow you
online I haven't actually signed up for
financial peace but I did register to
become a coordinator
um
we paid off our basic debt we paid off
for car debt we have our emergency fund
um
we we have our you know three to six
months
in savings so I think we're on four five
and six and then we just kind of went
okay we're good
you have no debt at all except your
house
uh well you're gonna yell at me I have 2
000 in credit card debt that we roll
over not roll over but our monthly
expense no wait were you listening okay
yeah I was Dave okay so you already got
yelled at a little bit for those
listening weeks I will give you all that
yes for those listening the past segment
we we yelled at some folks but here's
the thing Jason you you said you're a
long time listener you said you
understand the program you're choosing
to do something different
you're choosing to work your own plan
but you called us and I'm going to tell
you to cut up the credit cards and I'm
also going to look at you with a with a
smart look on my face and wonder why you
are doing that
uh honestly
the way it started for years I was cash
only before before your show
um and then we we weren't in a position
where we wanted to pay cash for a car
because it would have cut too much into
our savings
and we we just we had no credit so yeah
I'm sorry
whoa whoa whoa stop okay I've heard
about your plan
and you know about our plan what's your
question yeah
so the question
inside of my my two thousand dollar
credit card debt for the monthly bill
um I'm somewhere between steps four five
and six no you're not and I'm just
trying to figure out you're not working
this you're not working the baby steps
but what's your question then
okay what's your question so you want me
to pay off the credit card debt now what
is your question four five and six I
want you to tell me what your question
is
are you asking what baby step you're on
um I in my head I think I'm in
Babysitting step four you're in baby
step two you're in baby step four of
your head
but you have a different plan of baby
steps than we do
so no you're in baby step two you still
have credit card debt and you still have
credit cards so you still have Consumer
Debt 100 debt free with no credit cards
and debit cards in your pocket that you
use your money is baby step two
and you're not there okay and it's
inconvenient to pay cash for my car
because I don't want to limit my savings
is your plan
not a millionaire plan not a wealthy
person plan
a middle class person's plan I'm going
to leave money in savings at three to
five percent and borrow money to buy a
car at eight to twelve percent well
that's a freaking genius move
I mean so you what you've got to decide
Jason is and it's Okay We're not gonna
be mad at you but don't walk around
telling people that you're on a baby
step because you're not doing any of it
you're doing your deal
and one of my friends who's a a wealthy
guy that still had been playing around
with that and stuff I was I was actually
speaking at an event and he and I ended
up having lunch after the event uh in
another city and he said you know I
finally did all your stuff and I'm like
what do you mean what do you mean you
did all my stuff because you ain't done
nothing I said right we've been friends
a long time and you've been stupid the
whole time unknown and he goes well what
do you mean he goes I said man you know
it's okay I still love you you're still
my friend but you don't do our stuff and
he goes no I really do I said what do
you mean he goes I did it all I'm 100
debt free I've got my emergency fund I
matter of fact I'm paying off my house
uh I paid off my house two weeks ago oh
wow and so he's baby step seven right he
did it all and I said what changed and
he goes well I finally had to submit
myself
to the process that you laid out because
I kept thinking I could figure it out
faster than you could and I forgot that
you're the guy on this yeah yeah and he
go and he goes and oh by the way when
you're doing the stuff in my world
you're going to submit yourself to my
way because I'm the expert there and I'm
like I'm in smart dad you know I mean
but you have to you know you got to find
a proven thing and then do the thing not
ish it I mean ish is a wish Dave you're
on the radio
we're on the radio what is a number 16
show
Financial expert
and when we I'll talk about myself from
before I got here I listen to you and I
listen to the other personalities
because I'm like they're in that
position they understand money I'm a
layperson I'm just trying to scratch and
Claw my way do I really think that I've
got a better method or am I going to go
for the folks if you that have helped
millions of other people do it and if
you do it's okay
go do that it's okay we don't have to be
mad about it I'm not mad about it but
here's the thing if you want to do the
stuff we're talking about
do it yeah and it'll work
it's a proven
process screwing around with it and ish
in it
you know I'm ish I'm ramsey-ish
yeah it just doesn't work Jason it
doesn't work my bro
friends and you keep your car payment
and your credit cards and we'll still be
friends and I'll just be your Rich
friend
and so I get a little frustrated with it
Dave I'm not gonna lie well it is it is
frustrating but you know it's just but
but it it
but the frustration is not because of
like we're insulted because we want we
love you yeah we love you we want you to
win
we want you to do better yeah and we
want you to turn the corner on this
stuff and so but it's like a lot of
things in life have you ever had a
friend that was you know trying to quit
drinking or trying to quit misbehaving
and and you wanted it for them more than
they wanted it for them yes yeah that
that's the frustrating part because we
we see it and we know and we get it and
welcome to the Ramsey Show yeah so there
you go yeah cause we love you and we I
mean but everybody's got stupid people
that they love I mean you know we all do
and I'm the stupid people that other
people
I love Dave but he's crazier than a bean
you know I mean it's okay
that's all right I'm good with that
you don't have to be we don't have to be
mad about it we don't have to troll
somebody about it or something like that
it's just a matter of are you gonna do
this stuff it's like I hired a personal
trainer and he's got a six-pack I got a
keg right and um I'm like and he tells
me what I need to eat now if I don't eat
what he says
then I'm I'm not gonna look like him
well that it's one thing to not eat what
he says but don't sit there and argue
with them about it I I'm actually a
nutrition specialist check out this
belly
laughs
right some of the folks are obviously
taking in more food than you so I I am I
know more than you